[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're clapping in the New Year welcome
everybody back to the break room the
nerdy news show that tells you what you
need to know we are thrilled to be back
in 2023 right first episode of the year
um coming up on today's episode the name
is Johnson Aaron Taylor Johnson does it
because it's shaking not Johnson
um we've of course got our regular
feature the Patti LuPone update
um Hugh Jackman keeps teasing us about
Deadpool
Deadpool you Bogan
um and we're gonna go through all of the
releases of 2023. we're gonna pick our
favorites our sleeper hits we're gonna
have some hot takes some debates some
surprise releases oh some surprise
releases even all of that on today's
episode with me uh to do all that and
more I'm Zach Huddleston I've got uh
sipping from his Barbie cup Brandon
Barrick
tastes like success oh uh speaking of
success Jessica Clemens is here no
success here because I didn't get a
Barbie mug for Brandon for Christmas
you're a win you're a winner in all of
our hearts and then Tommy Bechtel camera
four please it's already there Cheryl's
cookies I ordered Jessica Potter and her
mom Linda a Santa Claus cookie set that
was to be delivered December 23rd
granted an unprecedented storm hit the
Seattle Washington area however I do not
believe Cheryl that your cookies still
have any Integrity on this January 3rd I
demand a full refund and cookies sent to
both of my main ladies Linda and Jessica
you are on warning and right now I
actually have an enemy newer than the
trash bags in the chat Cheryl's Cookies
you are my enemy please come on the
break room and sponsor the show you owe
me where's New Jersey on that list it
goes like this Cheryl's cookies
break room trash bags
I can't even acknowledge New Jersey
because to me it's a fictional place
like I think town like you're in town
Cheryl's Cookies was on a Southwest
flight I think that was the problem oh
you know what Cheryl if you're stuck in
the Denver Airport whipping up your
cookies in an airport but toilet then I
apologize let's just say her batter is
batter remember how we said did we get
to the we're gonna get to the point of
these shows a lot faster that's right
that's right I denied it on one minute
30 second shows cookies this one's on me
guys retention's on me today we're doing
official New Year's Redemption today uh
thank you for anybody uh throwing in
super chats we've already got a couple
in there thank you
um for every 100 we get in super chats
we're gonna go back through everybody
that uh send in the Super Chat and give
you your New Year's resolution you're
going to assign you an official new rock
stars New Year's resolution it's not too
late it's not too late it's not too late
um okay but let's get into the headlines
yes the headlines
oh okay so we were joking but Broadway
Megastar Patti LuPone uh did she
originate Evita the role of Evita on
stage I believe she did she's the girls
who lunch uh she was in uh sondheim's
coming she wasn't the original was she
also had the mom in um life goes on
anyways Steven Universe a legendary
actress there she is Patti LuPone uh
she's been added to the cast of Agatha
coven of chaos which this cast is that's
crazy that they're taking like uh
witches like and when I say witches
people like Aubry Plaza they're taking
like people that play these roles and
people that we think I'm just waiting
for them to get Stevie Nicks
oh my God I mean is a literal Diva
there's probably less than 10 people on
Earth that qualify more as a diva than
Patti LaBelle great story I got into it
more on inside Marvel last week it goes
on inside mobile can you believe it I
saw it uh where she there was a whole
kerfuffle between her and Angel Ed Weber
around Sunset Boulevard the show show
Glencoe stole her role stole it out from
us she did uh and she sued him and she
likes to say that Andrew Lloyd Webber
paid for her swimming pool oh yep yep
yeah she's she's great she's got a lot
of great quotes
um and speaking of great quotes Hugh
Jackman gave an interesting quote to
SiriusXM during an interview over the
holiday break where he mentioned a
potential plot element for Deadpool 3.
we have a clip we're gonna see if we can
play that clip of you because of this
device they have in the Marvel world of
moving around timelines now we can go
back
because you know it's science and
and so I don't have to screw with the
Logan timeline which was important to me
and I think probably to the fans
I can't hear him his accent's that thing
am I really bad at listening oh no he's
heavily sedated because he had to be put
in a mental institution I mean I didn't
he was in a padded cell there stole that
joke from Jessica during the
Breakthrough service
but the gist of that clip right you're
saying like there is a time travel
device yeah so he's kind of leaning into
time travel is he talking about where
Deadpool left off because they have the
one that they took for us yeah yeah I
mean it could be that it could be
something else new entirely there was
that weird thing that happened where
Ryan Reynolds like tweeted back at the
Miss minutes Twitter which is maybe
official maybe not official you think
it's a Kang situation it could be that
it could be like it's still around last
time I heard she got destroyed by
cogsworth stop we left that in 2022
Tommy some jokes are Eternal
um grandfather clocks and hammers in the
chat please oh my God
yeah Hugh Jackman's out there he's doing
I mean he's there he was talking about
Deadpool he's doing promo he has that
new uh animated show koala man produced
by Justin royland that just had a
trailer come out this is real I'm not
making those out yeah he's bringing
breaking news to the three of us right
now uh anyways so what we enjoy I mean
you know he'll probably again one of the
all-time great interviews uh Hugh
Jackman will probably sneak out all
kinds of other details for a film that
has not even begun filming yet yeah so
who knows he's a cheeky little secret
man isn't it
[Music]
the uh Matthew Bellini uh reporter in
Puck news and other places uh is
reporting that the James Bond franchise
will be shaking things up and perhaps
stirring a little excitement uh uh uh
apparently Aaron Taylor-Johnson uh met
with the bond producer and uh uh one of
the greatest named people of all time
Barbara broccoli for folks that don't
know the broccoli family controls the
James Bond uh franchise right it started
with Barbara brockley's father who's the
producer in all stock broccoli
cauliflower broccoli uh produced all of
the original Bond movies he passed on
but it's like they're they're
technically made by MGM but like that
studio has almost no control literally a
family controls who plays Bond when the
movies come out uh if they're ever
spin-offs that's why there's never been
a bond TV show contrast there was a
cartoon James Bond Junior that's true
now I do want to point out I do believe
what you're saying this that is why at
the end of the last James Bond movie
which I will not spoil for you does end
in a pretty conclusive fashion for James
still included James Bond will return
afterwards because you're sure a movie
studio would be like we can go ahead and
get this out of our own way the broccoli
family was like no no no no we're gonna
let everybody know James Bond will be
putting a movie out in the next five
years uh yeah and and yeah and and you
know a lot of those movies make tons of
money so it's in everybody's interest uh
but Aaron Taylor Johnson apparently they
had this great meeting he did an
audition it went really well he's
apparently like the right age and like
kind of Fame and skill level they're
looking for other names have been
floated I mean way back two or three
Bond movies ago names like Idris Elba
you know uh Clive Owen was always
mentioned I think around the time Daniel
Craig took over Luke now I think almost
everybody would agree eat yourself a
client but when those guys probably too
old they can play James Gold Bond God
damn cause they're gonna need some foot
some foot creams after they run all
those stunts all right you're gonna say
a Deez Nuts joke oh
okay joke to be dragon dragon these nuts
there you go the face of the break room
audience also I'm sure the region has
Aaron Taylor Johnson because of his
remarkable role in bullet train and just
how he looks and how he fights he's
great choreographed fighter and he's a
just a second man he's in great shape
and that was one of the rare roles he
got to use his natural British accent he
plays a lot of Americans I didn't know I
didn't know until my mom was like yeah
he's British he was kick ass it was also
John Lennon in uh Nowhere Boy yeah way
back in the day that was one that was
the first rule I ever saw man yeah he
was also uh in uh tenant I mean he's
working oh my gosh oh that's right of
course the kingsman Kingsman well and
this year and I don't want to spoil but
we're about to get into all the films
and shows they're gonna be coming out in
2023 he's gonna be craving the hunter
now what accent will he be using in
Cravings Australian maybe a little South
African oh I was gonna go Blood Diamond
with it maybe speaking of Craven a lot
of the viewers are craving these nuts
we actually listened to you
um whoa oh we have breaking news oh wow
breaking news deadline is reported that
Deborah Joe Rupp has been added to
Agatha Covenant of chaos what's
happening yes uh of course uh rep played
Wanda's neighbor in the first couple of
episodes we want to visit the mom from
That 70s Show in that 90s show kitty wow
Kitty Foreman
um producer John putting the stop it
lady and stop it the guy who does all
the great voiceovers played her husband
right yeah I forget what his name is the
tall ball guy with glasses yeah I forget
that guy's name uh wow uh again they're
trying to add every actress in Hollywood
as well added to flashback instead of
her because yeah because this because we
already know the dot the actress who
played Dottie is gonna be yeah and uh
confident cast so this yeah this could
be she might only be in like the first
episode breaking out or or perhaps a
shape-shifting uh a shape-shifting
mutant of sorts maybe entering uh whoa I
don't know it may be bringing up some
old memories for agathaway I would love
didn't save us you didn't save us
that's my there that's my Deborah Joe
rough impression uh an exclusive
interview with the directs Klein felt
senior character actor a senior
character animator on uh Spider-Man
across the spider-verse air Santos these
are names I'm sure I'm butchering I
apologize all these people revealed that
the film was originally an Avengers end
game like conclusion to the spider-verse
franchise he noted that the producers
were initially planning in-game-esque
stuff for this for the sequel now we
know we're getting two right we're
getting
um across the spider verse and what's
the third one
I guess across the spider versus part
one and two so that's too much oh really
another two parts the third one is just
going to be called across the spider
verse two I don't know if it has a title
yet
that is the nice thing about a
successful animated uh you know movie
based on a comic character you can
control the age much yes miles can stay
a teenager for 15 movies whereas Poor
Tom Holland uh in his growth stunting uh
drugs that they have him on yes as a as
an update we have broken the
as soon as we get through the headlines
we will dish out some delicious get your
super chat in now if you want to be
included in our badge a forced New
Year's resolution yeah you guys have no
choice if we call your name and give you
this resolution you need to send us
photo evidence of it within 365 days I
will come to your house oh boy and I
will paint your father's toenails oh no
oh that sounds like a good deal uh I'm
very bad with my hand yeah still be so
messy um Daredevil born a good start
Charlie Cox says fans shouldn't
necessarily take the show's title to
mean that it will be an adaptation of
the 1986 Marvel comic story of the same
name by Frank Miller and David musicelli
it's so it makes me so upset I think is
the name yeah just don't use the name
just don't I understand born again is
like oh yeah it does work both ways but
you're gonna get that the people that
are gonna be like oh like comic and
they're gonna have to be like no it's
just completely different kind of the
same title painted themselves in the
same corner with Vision Quest where it's
like that's a specific Comics right but
they already kind of told half of that
story so yeah yeah why don't they just
call it Daredevil accepting Christ into
your heart for eternal life
well pointed out including you guys
before we started rolling that like a
lot of the actual born-again comic
storyline has already been used in the
Netflix it was used in the last season
yeah exactly all the hair yeah not the
heroines well maybe they're shaving that
part well and they're still like we've
only had rumored but debunked reports of
Eldon Hansen and uh uh uh Deborah and
wall being in this
shows just inofrio and Cox have been
confirmed yeah uh Loki season two uh
shared some new images as part of a
Disney 2023 Sizzle reel I think we have
those images oh okay hello we know that
guy smokey's in the shop
and he's falling again
he loves to fall we've seen some of
those before or like you could have
convinced me almost all of those were
from season one and we saw some of them
were in like the little teaser they
showed at d23 some of those shots so
yeah so mission impossible one Vibes in
that one scene when he was like doing
this yeah
thank you John he's having so much fun
opposed to and uh what was it Thor
Ragnarok when he was following he was
pissed about it only forever yeah
um speaking on the Empire podcast uh
Black Panther what kind of forever star
Leticia Wright revealed that Marvel
Studios originally planned to have both
shuri and Chadwick boseman's t'challa
serve as the Black Panther
simultaneously as before obviously
Chadwick uh Chad boseman's tragic
passing uh when asked about her emotions
putting the suit on for the first time
right looked back on it uh being a
Bittersweet moment while sharing that
shuri was always going to do it she
explained that she and Bozeman would
have suited up alongside each other uh
trying to figure out how best to defend
wakanda together
um and of course there's a a big comic
storyline where Sherry is Black Panther
at the same time uh uh t'challa is
um and and she she went on to say that
like uh you know they would both be
black panther alongside each other try
to figure out how to defend their Nation
together which would have been I mean
it's a nice natural thing in sequels to
films and kind of like Batman gets his
Robin or whatever you know you kind of
expand the talent pool a little bit
they're still kind of doing it because
it was a situation I think it was more
than the one run that I read but in one
run she was the Black Panther while he
was doing the like political stuff so
it's basically kind of still doing that
with uh wasn't see Duke right as in Baku
and shout out to my sister Teresa who
got me the Black Panther wakandan herbs
shower set from Target I forgot what the
brand is no but I'm waiting to see if
those herbs give me power I went to the
Press junk and they gave me jerk chicken
seasoning and I finally used it okay
yeah I feel like my my ancestral plane
is just a holiday in bar that's all my
grandparents going God the war was
harder than we thought it was going to
be which war they fought in a lot of
water wow which side
some good some bad hey
um let's just say they participated in
all of them don't Google my last name uh
a quick little programming note
something we're excited about Marvel has
forewarned us we are getting the second
big Ant-Man in the last quantumanium
trailer next Monday a week from today as
part of the BCS National Championship
game sometime during that game they're
gonna uh debut the trailer
um and we are gonna wait next Monday
we're not gonna go live at our normal
time 305 sharp 305 sharp Pacific uh
we're gonna go live as soon as that
trailer comes out and we're gonna do a
live break room reaction to that trailer
uh in the moment so if you're watching
the football game or you're just paying
attention to Twitter or whatever you see
that that trailer is live check out the
new rockstars Channel we will be you
know five minutes later we're going to
be live reacting to it talking about all
of it it's your second screens ready no
yes and just uh as a speculative as a
sports fanatic who has participated in
many of these trailer drops I would say
the odds are go from going in from the
second quarter to the halftime show
would be when they do it or possibly
coming back into the third quarter from
the halftime show like that would be my
I would you know you know keep your eyes
and ears feel to the internet what time
is that well I mean it does it depends
on how long it will depend on the game
starts at 4 30 p.m Pacific uh next
Monday so we're hoping maybe six but
it's pretty much like the Super Bowl you
know the ads that are the most expensive
are the first and second quarter ads and
the ads going into the house so fingers
crossed for a low scoring grind it out
burn clock
Georgia get that run game going yes TCU
you know fold maybe quit
um and uh one final note here or one
final headline so um black panther
wakanda forever is going to be on Disney
Plus on February 2nd it was announced uh
we knew that was it's kind of about
remember first
cool sorry did I put February 1st I put
February well it will also be on there
February that's right I just wanted to
give it one less day during Black
History Month get out of Tommy I just
said
um oh that is oh that is interesting it
is the first day of like yeah do is
there an actual math to it is three
months after it's down there well so
there hasn't really been established
when things go on Disney plus now when
things are released on 4K and Blu-ray
and whatever is typically about 45 days
yeah
and so we're anticipating I don't think
it's been announced we're anticipating
middle of this month we'll get Blu-ray
and things like that can I ask can I ask
a quick question amongst the three of
you that I'm actually interested in feel
free dashville and John if you want to
chime in did you guys buy any physical
media this Christmas season I did not uh
I don't think so I'm starting back up
I'm back okay here we go are you buying
blue race what do you got I bought Top
Gun okay I got a digital download in 4k
and I am uh currently shopping around
for some new ones but did you say a
digital download yeah you get the
download too oh okay I thought you only
got the digital no no no you got to buy
it some of them have like Blu-ray media
I like the idea of having a physical
media collection back and if I'm Gonna
Fill my home with my mansion with
trinkets I'd rather it is it is better
and even if somebody says streaming in
4k it's not 4K there's still compression
I don't know I just I think I'm back in
I know it maybe is a waste of money and
maybe this is like you know yet another
Vice hey hey uh HBO Max is proven you
can't rely on the stuff being streaming
don't take it off they'll rip it out of
your hands right uh we're gonna do these
forced uh um uh New Year's resolutions
here in a second but first we want to
ask if you're saving more and spending
less than one is one of your top goals
for 2023 absolutely uh if you're still
paying like insane amounts of money
every month for your phone bill stop
doing it don't do it okay right now when
you switch to Mint mobile you'll get
their unlimited plan for 50 off that's
half off 50 off man mobile was the first
company to sell premium wireless service
online only and MIT mobile lets you
order from home and save a time with
phone plans starting at just 15 a month
but you have to hurry because this deal
ends January 15th 15 15 bucks a month by
the 15th of January okay they're kicking
off the year with their best offer ever
baby before January 15th buy any three
month plan and get three months free
even on their unlimited plan that's a
good plan uh by going online only and
eliminating the traditional cost of
retail mint mobile passes significant
savings onto you and all plans come with
unlimited talk and text plus high-speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5G Network use your own phone you got a
phone you like you can keep it uh it's
very easy you can switch in minutes just
with their e-sim program switch to Mint
mobile and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month buy
any three month Mobile plan and get
three months more free by going to
mintmobile.com break room that's
mintmobile.com breakroom cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
midmobile.com breakroom hurry because
again this offer ends on January 15th
keep your phone keep your number keep
your contacts and real quick stop
multiple people this is real multiple
people in the new Rockstar staff have
mint mobile including several of our our
editors I believe Tommy Bechtel is in
the process of switching to Mint mobile
right I will soon be a minty man I was
but a Verizon boy before and now I will
be a minty man I had my mint Mitzvah
should we do these resolutions real
quick yes yes okay great so if you uh
send in a Super Chat and this won't
necessarily be the last time we do this
but this will be one batch if you're
sending the Super Chat we're going to
give you your forced New Year's
resolution
um we we have a list here we'll also be
improvising some okay I'll start with a
couple match 143 thank you for your
Super Chat uh your resolution you
actually this year you have to give up
beer but uh you have to drink hard
kombucha oh that is your resolution low
alcohol Bernard McQueen
Bernard McCoy
thank you for your Super Chat you
need to download Chris Hemsworth workout
app and never open it just like me
here's an easy one yeah oh yeah
uh uh Phil rachman you want more quiz
Master 2023 so your resolution is going
to be to watch the Batman on point five
speed wow very slow get this man out of
here
six hours of your life Hannah baso I
think I remember you because you keep
telling me I need new glasses how about
you read less books
oh that's a good one our friend GSU
Eagle 117 uh frequent uh member of the
chat there thank you for your super chat
um your uh forced New Year's resolution
uh you're gonna have to learn to parkour
blindfolded
David Henry Bennett
said getting my name in also miss y'all
have been having Marvel withdrawals well
nothing takes away those Marvel
withdrawals then like a quick hit of DC
animation David Henry Bennett I give you
this resolution of
refer to Elizabeth Olsen only as Lizzy
oh you really hate that one and Robert
De Niro is Bob I'm adding that in and Al
Pacino as Alfonso okay wow Tanya Tyler
by the end of the year you have to eat
an entire brick oh whoa you can spread
it out over the years yeah just a
Grainer yeah
smackaboo every time you wake up in the
morning look in the mirror and say wow I
suck
it'll keep you humble smack himself
Kiana Chanel
um your resolution is I want you to look
in the mirror every morning when you
wake up and say smack a boo sucks
my boy Bucky Barnes uh
uh welcome back and we're gonna give you
uh
let's see here gotta be careful with
this one turn your bedroom into a disco
man and then have a little dance party
Trey Scott Wharton uh you have to walk
less and drive more smart sorry Planet
Drive Walk Drive Drive your carbon
footprint uh Berger Stephenson you have
a a great
um
uh great name I assume you're from a
Nordic country possibly Verger or
somewhere somewhere that is not the US
uh yours is and this might be tough for
you you can only eat at Buffalo Wild
Wings
well it might be tough if he lives in
Denmark or something like that I think
the Buffalo Wild Wings are referred to
as Buffalo
I think they're elk Wild Wings Stacy
you don't need any new things you're
good to go baby Grant swingleberg
oh we meet again resolution is getting
my tweets reply to you by everyone on
the break room bad news Grant we all
blocked yeah
replace all your kitchen utensils with
sex toys
I can't flip my pancakes I can you're
not using the right tool you're not
gonna flip the pancakes you're gonna
[ __ ] your pancakes
yo that's not syrup uh sham sham the Sim
12. uh you gotta throw away your couch
so sorry throw it away by yourself no
help no no help throw away um Aaron
storm and uh Tasha Tasha you know what
you guys have a combined resolution I
want you two to be friends wow
Natasha Tasha you two become friends you
have to be friends yeah Bucky Barnes I'm
gonna give you another one boy thank you
for your kind thoughts uh or your kind
wishes on Demar Hamlin as uh uh we won't
go into that because it's very sad story
but thank you for saying that and I wish
for you to use ranch dressing on all
your hot fudge sundaesar that's gross
get ranched uh and then final two ones
here we got to give another one to
snackaboo
uh confront your parents yeah about
anything that's a good just confront
them yeah get it out and then Christian
unpronounceable are fun Canadian friend
who's also a frequent uh member of the
chat thank you Christian how about
um uh you know what
tell your dad you love him and then
under your breath say psych yes that's
what I do every time okay you know what
at the Christian because you have been
so consistent let me give you a bonus
one this year I want your resolution to
be to dance like everyone like
everyone's watching they're all judging
you on a great reality show called
Christian undansable oh
um
I'm gonna get into
the year to come 2023 all the releases
coming out we're gonna uh try to list
out everything we think is going to be
of interest to the new rock stars
audience we're gonna stop and maybe chat
about a couple of them have some hot
takes maybe do some red flag green flag
here and there now I'm going to start by
talking about January unfortunately this
year starts a little sleepy okay not a
lot of big releases sub to some uh not a
big releases of January it's going to
end a little sleepy the middle of this
year is nuts okay we'll get to that
January we really only have we got bad
batch season two comes out on Wednesday
please
bad bat season 2 comes out on Wednesday
and we know from our viewers that they'd
like some bad batch content we also know
Eric Voss is missing somewhere yeah
presumed uh he claims to be on vacation
because I used to be on vacation and you
know what I like to say
well the Voss is away Beck Baca
is gonna make some bad batch comments
okay so keep your eyes keep your eyes
down for a little bad batch from the
back batch that back [ __ ] back [ __ ]
no okay so bad match comes out this week
um also later this week and another
thing you should keep an eye out on the
channel for Megan the horror movie about
the little uh cursed doll comes out we
wrote Megan in the uh prompter and I
think it's m3gen this is uh
Studio that made the invisible uh Man
movie and the purge movies and they tend
to make really good fun uh horror movies
so we're really excited about that movie
and then really the only other big thing
in January besides maybe some trailers
maybe some surprises The Last of Us
starts on HBO uh January 15th in about
two weeks we are definitely going to be
covering that on the channel we're going
to be doing episodic breakdowns of all
of that we're really excited I'm excited
because I know nothing about this as
I've said before these hands were cursed
by the gaming Gods these thumbs are
meant only for thumbs up not for playing
video games the last of us will be new
for me here's a good question do you
guys think that last of us season one
will do better I think House of the
Dragon season oh absolutely wow
listen I love fastest Dragon but I think
red flag green fight I think it's a
fresh fresh show fresh start and I think
it'll be a surprise as HBO reached out
to invite us to the premiere of last
night no and if they would they'd get a
Green Fighter but but well here's what
I'll say in Brandon's defense
I mean the first season the first couple
seasons of Walking Dead were Mega hits
people love a zombie show so I mean
there's a chance but there's so much
lore Behind The Walking Dead and it was
I think it was a lot longer than the
last of us was to the series right like
the comics for the watch I've been
around for a while yeah yeah but also
those were based on comics
Tommy's being a stinker okay but that's
that's January again it's a little work
this year's slowly warming up and then
it really gets hot in February oh baby
February yo my little Valentine that's
the song calendar girl Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum Mania comes out February
17th
2013 three days after Valentine's
thirteen well did I say to that 2023
we'll all be rehydrated from our
vigorous love making on Valentine's Day
ready to go see Ant-Man in the WASP
quantumania that date also important
that's the launch of Deep dive uh-oh our
first sister Channel Hey Deep dive new
Rockstar Deep dive if you've seen the uh
big announcement video that we put out a
couple days ago there's some good
information there I'll be able to Deep
dive to escape from Eric after all my
bad batches well he was away now we also
have what if now season two was supposed
to be early 2023 but we have no news and
no trailer and just the tea so that
there's going to be like blood and an
nc7 or ma17 rating we assume it's going
to be pushed but you never know said
maybe February February maybe we get
whatever did you kind of treat what if a
little bit differently yeah it's kind of
you know it's the cartoon steps on it's
maybe got a little bit of red hair we've
talked about we don't have any release
dates for any of the Marvel shows in
2023 yet yeah what so I think they're
just focusing on the uh the movies
because there's so many this year after
this versus I mean they know but I think
it's like I think it's easier to show
you push those ones around them without
telling people those are the movies
doesn't it cost like a lot of them when
they move that around versus you have to
move it with the theater I mean we can
look at last year right they were like
oh canobie's gonna come out on this day
and then they're like just kidding it's
gonna come out two days early yeah like
okay well even even with the Marvel
special presentations yeah they don't
promote those ahead of time right and
they only announced it like a few weeks
ahead of time the date so that's a good
thing we don't know but um again we're
very excited otherwise uh quantumania is
going to be huge we're very excited
about that uh okay moving into March in
March you know St Patrick's Day March
17th but actually on March 1st we got
Mandalorian season three everyone's
excited for
um
[Laughter]
Dungeons and Dragons also drops March
3rd yeah which we're very excited I'll
see any movie with Chris Pine in it
maybe Oh yeah and when he already did
some primers for it right we need to
have some videos actually go check those
back out and then come back because
Creed 3 is also dropping dragons those
are playing those are based on a popular
role-playing game right yeah
also me and me and Tommy will probably
go over Creed Three yeah yeah oh you
know we'll we will be talking Creed
Three all things Creed Three I'm so
excited we also have Shazam Fury of the
Gods the second one on March 17th now
that's St Patrick's Day right yeah
Shazam through the gods and this is so
far so far the only install the second
the second and the last we don't know if
they're gonna McDonald's anymore we
don't know I hope they make more I
thought Shazam was cute I think I think
if anything survives the DC do we want a
third shazam movie Red Flag green flag I
know oh yeah can I see the second one
first yeah that's a good point but I
think I want to see him I like Shazam I
would I would also maybe rather prefer
Billy Batson uh be uh brought into some
DCU films I think maybe more than like a
third Shazam film I again I gotta see
the second one I'd love to see Billy he
gets the flash treatment and pulled into
whatever weird
hierarchy of the DCU forever yeah we
might get Shazam and Peacemaker which
would be great together
John Wick four yeah John Wick four which
please don't push just let it out and
I'm gonna go crazy on it uh I have one
more sleeper hit for March that I'm
gonna throw in there Barry Mason season
two
on HBO Max folks if you love a little
old school Los Angeles 1930s Los Angeles
delicious show go back and watch the
first season real real interesting story
great little mystery a lot of gross
violence uh but check it out a really
good show and I'm very hyped for season
two of uh Perry Mason yeah here's a
here's a bonus uh New Year's resolution
go watch Perry Mason season one that's
what we're watching that's a lot of
times I auditioned to play a drunk uh
like uh mortician on that show or like
autopsy guy oh the guy who got the role
is a famous Broadway actor who's really
great whose name I forget my head but
he's really great
I will never tell you okay April we
think we're maybe getting secret
Invasion it's just listed as spring tell
us the date Kevin feige tell us uh
that's gonna be hot very excited for
secret Invasion can't wait to see my boy
Talos coming back Ben Mendelson he
should be the next man no make Ben
Mendelson the next Spider-Man uh but
folks oof succession season four they're
saying spring but we're hoping April
I'm 100 feet tall and these people are
pygmies
succession I don't know folks in the
chat are watching succession [ __ ] off if
you're not watching
and now we really the the summer of 2023
is Bonkers through July is three months
of just some of the best content you're
ever you're gonna get May Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol 3. the conclusion of the
Guardian soccer As Told by James Gunn in
that cast boom May 5th that's kicking
off the month in middle of the month you
get fast 10. whoa we've already hit 10
Fast and Furious movies about the 11th
for free right if you if you got your
punch card
um and that's again not to mention
there's probably going to be a Marvel
show still running at that time right
like uh whether it's secret Invasion
what if some other shows that we haven't
even mentioned yet like we'll probably
be running concurrent for some of May as
fast uh fast 10 Universal yes yeah
gotcha yeah yeah
right into this I mean contenders for
the bigger month June and July are both
going to be oh my God
June
June yeah Happy Father's Day well happy
Daddy's day Loki season two we think
maybe June I mean it definitely has a
narrower window right we found out over
the break that the window for the
release went over Loki has been narrowed
down yeah it could be June it was June
when it came out before right Joe also I
believe it's Sunday in June 2020. June
Gloom this year baby because across the
spider verse wow webs are flowing up
like all right anyway uh June 2nd June
2nd that's great Transformers rise of
the Beast coming out in June 9th the
very next week you're the voice Tommy do
the voice Optimus let them come oh and I
will Peter Cullen's shaking
all right that's only the second week of
the month you still got two more weeks
there's two more weeks in June come
cough let's all sleep the rest of the
time just kidding we can't because that
flash movie a real will they won't day
for the last two years of Our Lives is
dropping June 16th is it coming out then
guys red flag green flag does that movie
come out that week I think they gotta
put it out
one more point of no return they're
gonna push it one more when I say one
more it's not gonna be like three months
it's gonna be like two weeks something's
gonna happen they already moved it
because of Indiana Jones five right yeah
yeah yes they did now after the
inevitable press disaster following the
flash when the lead act the lead actor
goes on a rampage at a Kroger Indiana
Jones will drop to cleanse our pallets
Indiana Jones 5 coming out June 30th
2023 dial of distance do you cry during
Indiana Jones five oh yeah no no I won't
be able to cry because I'll have already
been so dehydrated from
coming
and in July I won't have any tears left
to give July is going to be heavy for us
too folks yes we got mission impossible
7. oh my God July 14th they said not on
the fourth of July Cinema is back score
safety and then we have a double feature
that we're all here oh my God
together twice in the same day we're
gonna see Oppenheimer yeah and the
Barbie movie shot Chaser
yes oh yeah real quick if you do it yeah
if you do a double feature which one I
think you do Barbie first you've got to
do Barbie's gonna be sure better than
Oppenheimer I don't want to go into app
and I don't want to go into Barbie
depressed thinking about Oppenheimer and
being like sorry Miss it well they're
doing cute little dance numbers and Ken
and Barbie are rollerblading I'm like
man really is gonna destroy this thing I
went the opposite because I want I want
to go dark but then I want Barbie to
make me feel better should I go home
feeling good
if armor wasn't going to be a long movie
can we can we rent a cinema
and have them show us Oppenheimer then
we take like a 30 minute pallet cleanser
just show a Rick and Morty episode to
just get us kind of into like back into
like the mode of laughter and then we do
Barbie I like that idea we'll go see
Oppenheimer and Barbie and then see no
movies for exactly one more week and
then we'll go see the marbles well also
also to be fair
we will have already seen Barbie because
there's no way the break room ain't
getting on that Pink Carpet
we will be there we're renting that
Corvette we're going we're showing up
we're showing up with Angeline that's
right
Angeline and the four of us somehow
fitting in that tiny escort I'll get in
the trunk
um put me right on the hood and then
just just as as uh is that what you're
saying right the four big movies that
come out that month are like four movies
you want to see all four of them Mission
Impossible seven Oppenheimer Barbie the
Marvel campus and they're all so
different they're also so we have our
superhero movie we have the Barbie movie
on Oppenheimer a historical movie and
the mission impossible in action movie
just coming back and a reminder I mean
you can make an argument who won 2022
Maverick
Mavericks
this could be this could be as big as
Maverick we don't you don't think that
Avatar snuck in at the end at 1 20 20.
do that count maybe box office wise but
I mean like the hearts of Mines were
I'll tell you what spider won 2022 for
biggest jackass in my book now listen to
me these during July we may have to do
so we may have to supplement our
material we have to have like a break
room movie discussion thing because
there's going to be full day discussions
all of these movies I don't even know
how we're going to get the headlines
don't break any news in those months
listen to me please listen to me Warner
Brothers you keep your mouth shut during
this month now for the back half of the
Year we're less confirmed on a lot of
these dates we've got a lot of
speculation here August so excited my
birth month gonna finally turn 21.
we're gonna do a champagne toast for you
no I was born in 2002 I turned 20. this
is huge this is gonna be big for me uh
he had a sweet 20th Blue Blue Beetle is
scheduled yeah August 18th 2023. it's
avoided The Swinging sword of zazlov
it's still gonna come outside
here's my question with Blue Beetle it
was probably written with the mindset of
it was in the DC EU yeah do we think it
still is there or are they gonna try and
put it into the DCU in somehow the plus
side is that it's an introduction to
Blue so they don't even have to
incorporate we talked about this with
the MCU in phase four they don't need to
incorporate anything else in there they
keep this on Earth and then keep this as
a Blue Beetle introduction so no that
makes a lot of sense Brandon is so
surrounded in this movie or am I crazy
uh that's true she's in the movie Sue
Sarandon green flags for Sue
I broke it off right yeah she's a single
lady yeah she was with a guy who owned a
ping pong club for a while she co-owned
that ping pong that's right thank you
Zach by the way Sarandon watch every
Tuesday night on the Deep dive I don't
want to keep pitching shows that are
going to be on that channel Eric will be
going into Susan Sarandon's personal
life for about two hours
it's gonna be called balls deep in Susan
yeah
guys no let's talk about September
nothing coming out well never forget
well what one thing we're not sure
to get into the fall so as you get into
the fall again some of these series we
don't know when they're coming out like
we know ironheart is coming out in the
fall yeah fall could mean August
September October November we don't know
same with X-Men 97 yeah is going to be
sometime in the fall uh so it might be
September it might be October the only
thing we know for sure October we're
getting
100. speaking of Aaron Taylor Johnson
and we're hoping it doesn't move again
it got shifted with uh Madam Webb right
yeah yes and we got a chameleon in that
movie it was going to be the chameleons
there is yeah that's fun yeah hey
Spider-Man's first villain in the
comments I'm back in you know Spider-Man
was based on a comic book okay well you
know I thought it was a Sega Genesis
game you know it's all based off a comic
book in November we have X-Men 97.
uh friend of the channel Frank Moran
working on that series come on the show
frankly I think he has definitely agreed
to come on the show whatever we want him
so uh if you'll tell us the release date
he can come on yes uh he probably
doesn't know it maybe go some swag ooh
Frank swag maybe a Premiere and right
for the game he's like stop asking the
yellow carpet yeah we're gonna walk that
yellow carpet ew no and then dude I've
walked out a few yellow carpets
Playmates
okay they started as white carpets
um okay dude two I don't want to brush
over due to the movie I'm most excited
about the spice must flow yeah okay I'm
a chalamet Stan from the jump dude one
was a Transcendent experience for me
okay I loved every second of that I
rewatched that movie regularly I am so
excited for doing wearing the wearing
what's it called weirding weirding
modules yes
um very excited you should have been in
that movie you are perfect for dude can
we get him in Dune too is it too late
yeah it's probably two what's the name
of the guy Denny man
no way Huddleston get him in
uh and then we close out the gear and
then we're going to talk about some
things that we're not exactly sure or
maybe rumored or whatever but December
closed out pretty good we know
um uh uh Agatha Covenant of chaos yeah
he's like called late 2023 early 2024.
so probably like um book of Boba Fett at
the beginning of 2022. it might start in
December end in January
and then we know we're getting Aquaman
in the lost kingdom yeah uh there kind
of finishing out the already shot uh DC
EU that's right the movie's finished was
ready to come out this past December
2022 and they got pushed it back yeah I
think there's something they did a bunch
of Love Letter to the DC EU that you
care that you so deeply treasured comes
to an end on Christmas day they had to
put Superman in it the minute it takes
Superman it's a mess and then we know
right like there are some things that
were kind of delayed or kind of in The
Ether so like the echo series it's
already been shot it's kind of like
there's some reshoots it's been kind of
delayed or temporarily removed from the
schedule something like that that could
still come out in 2023 they might get
bumped to 2024.
um other shows we just don't know when
they're coming out Ahsoka Ahsoka that
that um some Rosario Dawson playing that
character Star Wars yeah we've seen a
little bit of footage right we got did
we get an additional room celebration
they had they were like two days of
image of Photography yes that's what
they they showed us that and we're
assuming right we know the date for
Mandalorian beginning of March that'll
run you know six eight weeks something
like that presumably Ahsoka is the next
Star Wars series so maybe that comes in
the spring I got a flag green flag oh
please guys so now that we know Rose
Rosie Dawson isoka I'm gonna shortening
everybody's names
Rosie Dawson sounds wrong it actually
sounds a little racist uh
you know we know it was already Dawson's
is do we think that she could come back
in Daredevil on board ah
do we not want I mean hey it's all
Disney but Daredevil went down unborn
life begins at conception I don't think
I don't think they want anyone from
Netflix other than Daredevil not even
Mega star Rosario Dawson you know I
think that's the reason why and I also
think she's in the fam I think Marvel
and Kevin feige would like to have
Rosario Dawson as a bigger character was
she even really in the last season
[Music]
I think all Attractive people should
work always hey
ugly people so does Hollywood ugly
people no pretty people yes
ugly people no pretty people yes so
after Ahsoka we also know uh a third
Star Wars series is scheduled for next
year Skeleton Crew this was Jude Law and
a bunch of kids
[Laughter]
no after Andor I'm excited for anything
that is them trying different things
like I like I love what fallony's doing
with the live action stuff but like
Mando and book of Boba Fett and Obi-Wan
I know that wasn't really full on you
but and then like Ahsoka it all kind of
feels similar and then Andor felt so
different really loved it really great
stuff I hope Skeleton Crew feels
different it's been pitched as like
gambling it's kind of like The Goonies
in space kind of a thing like he's in
space yeah hell yeah who's who's after
some some Goonies in space I find
Goonies were duck okay
uh okay so those are the the two Star
Wars series we don't know about yet and
then we know we're getting and this one
probably sooner rather than later yeah
the the boys spin-off gen V right uh is
coming confirmed in 2023 we're not sure
when and potentially The Boys season
four might sneak in there the thing is
they push those out very quickly they do
boys are really good at being like we're
gonna shoot all of this right now and is
it could it be as boys underground gonna
have to come back I'll break this down I
think it has to get better because they
just got chills they got delayed a
little bit because of the pandemic and
then what happened was they released
season three and then immediately
started season four uh uh Carl Urban put
up a post on Instagram they were all on
set in August of 2022 shooting so like
that show's got to come out this year I
think you're just like expecting for Gen
V to come out and then like literally
three months later yeah
huge hit for Amazon they they want that
to be like their big franchise speaking
if you did for Amazon uh Invincible yeah
the animated superhero show they're
bringing it back that first season was
heartbreaking and wild and crazy another
17 years yeah
um so that is coming potentially
soon-ish we've been told we're getting a
trailer this month they did the old
sometime between January 2nd of January
the shows are so cheeky on Twitter they
hear Jackman oh let's put a trailer out
in between January and February
[Laughter]
I'm an Australian witch hockey's package
is that a babadook
um and and we speaking of streaming
shows uh we also know for sure we're
getting Witcher season three the final
Henry Cavill Witcher season right it's
coming out probably in the first half of
20. and then he's done acting forever
war movie
maybe I made a connection maybe I went A
to Z there yeah you're like my mom
comparing Star Wars and Star Trek okay
they should be Vulcans in the Star Wars
and then um series we don't know we've
these things are in some state of
development but they have not given any
sense of when they're coming out Rick
and Morty season seven right season six
just kind of wrapped up pretty recently
A Stranger Things season five the final
the final final season hopefully kill
those kids before a spin-off kill some
kids before you know we're gonna get 10
seasons of spin-offs but oh yeah um that
Penguin series with Colin Farrell as
part of the uh Matt Reeves Batman
Universe that they're letting live on
its own
um we don't know that's been in the
works we gotta get out there and get the
penguin we can't let the penguin keep
getting away with this commissioner
please buy the penguin your voice is too
intimidating
uh okay
maker season two it's been a minute he's
making season one was way way
yeah
I also forget that he writes them too so
I'm like yeah I saw John Cena just lost
his opportunity at the title last week
on Smackdown so he's probably down and
out right now I don't know rumor is
WrestleMania Owen Zayn versina
[Music]
well or I mean you know one of the
rumors is uh John Cena Stone Cold Steve
Austin WrestleMania oh my gosh let's go
I hope some of us will be able to attend
I hope so um I wasn't invited
Star Wars show that that one we're just
starting to get casting stuff and like
some early set photos so they're just
working on it now is the acolyte the one
with uh uh mandala Sternberg or is that
yes yes okay okay I got a red flag green
flag for that for the Accolade I know
we're running out of time here acolyte
is it gonna is it gonna take the
Goodwill that Andor made with by getting
outside of the universe a little bit and
pushing us to areas we're unfamiliar
with are they gonna go too far are they
going to make it just right are they
land in the Andor Zone I think good I
because my hope is that that far in the
uh uh past yeah there's no Stormtroopers
there's no type Fighters again though
complaints from Star Wars fans about
Andor was like where is everybody I want
that I want that one Speaking of which
my complaints will probably be there
unfortunately but everyone else we know
right you are we know we're getting an
Andor season two now they've been a
little vague I think you know maybe you
could sneak in at the end of 2023
probably more likely 2024 yeah but it
could sneak in there and then there's
some you know there's probably other
things that were and and we didn't go
into there's some other horror movies
that are evil dead rise and we just got
a teaser for
um there's that 65 the atom driver
sci-fi movie it looks pretty fun look at
that little trailers yeah it's okay a
little fence soup I don't know
performance the driver is acting oh I'll
watch a driver performance oh hell yeah
uh he could driver my car right uh
should we do a couple more yes uh
resolutions on the way out so many great
super chats while you guys listen to us
ramble so much
um uh oh bye Bob Rogers foot I apologize
there's no way I said that well uh my
mom your forced New Year's resolution is
uh I just want you to think about what
you've done yeah yeah think long and
hard about what you've done and if you
are actually a murderer that hasn't
confessed yet think a little less and
don't take it out on us
Boogie's World AKA what I call my nose
uh
miss y'all glad you guys are back
Boogie's world
oh man your resolution this year
stop bugging
stand still World film juice you sounded
a very generous Super Chat thank you so
much uh you should save that money
though because your resolution is you
have to marry your waifu pillow oh my
food
juice you got to keep messing
yeah
Diana Santos uh your New Year's
resolution is to become my sister oh let
me tell you I'm not a good sister I will
wear your clothes and steal your straw
uh project Odin you have to write an
autobiography and release it on Amazon
oh oh that's a good one finish it before
the year's over yeah Quentin is the last
one right because yeah our last time
yeah thank you to everybody that sent in
a Super Chat nope there's more sorry I'm
being told I'm getting a call right now
uh all right I quit
because it's such a great name I think
he deserves for us to sing the New
Year's resolutions who's gonna sing it
oh we all have this thing you take that
romp roast and you put it on the slicer
DJ cold cuts this year be a little nicer
stop telling your mom that you think
she's a [ __ ] don't get mad when you
fail that Nintendo switch DJ Cool Cuts
2023 is the year you stop being such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay
that's beautiful
oh thank you to everybody Kitty DJ I'm
sure you're a nice man and you commented
cold cut so you may not even be sentient
the piece of baloney hooked up I'm
making a rare AI ew a piece of below and
he's just slapping the keyboard that's a
Tick-Tock joke for those of you kids
that are stamps and sauces no cat she
[Applause]
said
what a great way to start the year uh
thank you to everybody that's super
chatted well really it was a great
turnout for this chat today we're and we
will let you know regardless we might
have thrown up some red flags Brandon
might have thrown some shade at Adam
driver side by movie we are excited
about everything we talked about today
we're gonna probably gonna make content
about it on the channel maybe multiple
pieces of content we're probably going
to talk about it on the break room and
we're so happy we hope you are here with
us yes another great year in the break
room baby we survived it now no matter
what they say this is a multi-year show
oh okay the haters they said weeks and I
said
months
maybe even years so in order this year
I'm excited for Mid mobile becoming a
mid man getting in the drive-by Squad
that's Adam Driver fans finding DJ cold
cuts helping them become a better person
that's a beautiful stuff we're a full
sandwich
um thank you all so much have a great a
great 2023 and a great rest of your
evening thanks guys
[Music]
foreign